[Musik]
[Applaus]
drauß vom walde komm ich her da steht
zurzeit keinen bäumchen mehr alle tannen
abgehackt der klimaschutz wird volker
das ist heiligabend ich weiß ich sie es
am weihnachtsbaum einer von 25 bis 30
millionen trümmerteilen die bei uns
jedes jahr auf dem müll landen gar nicht
gut für den co2 abdruck moment dass
länder obmann tanne mit wurzelballen im
topf die die ist nicht gekauft dies
gebietet die wird nach den feiertagen
wird er war sofort wieder eingepflanzt
hier co2 abdruck top ten
[Musik]
wer ist der geilste um mit frau
heuchelei beim ausbuddeln pkw zu denen
die stadt karten nach sechs wochen
wieder aus der stadt kamen mit dem lkw
und ein titel ist also nachhaltig der
immer noch besser als wegschmeißen
er steht wochen lang in eurer beheizten
mit bude trocknet völlig aus sondern
soll er da draußen wieder anwachsen
ein großer weihnachtsbaum vermieter hat
eingeräumt dass 2017 nur die hälfte der
bäume die vermietung überlebt hat
heuchelei faust
[Musik]
echte kerzen
ja was soll ich sagen die machen einfach
das schönste licht nicht gegangen
billig kerzen enthalten paraffin das
gewinnt man aus erdöl
deswegen haben wir auch extra nicht die
billigsten genommen hochwertige gärten
einhalten stehen
das wird aus tier und pflanzenwelt
gemacht warum oder aus palmöl dafür wird
viel urwald gerodet
[Musik]
außerdem enthalten viele kerzen duft und
farbstoffe unbedenklich sind dagegen
kerzen aus reinem bienenwachs die kommen
allerdings wegen des hohen bedarfs
meistens aus industrieller imkerei und
müssen dazu auch noch importiert werden
hey hier so eine led lichterkette ist
einmal im jahr ok denke ich um ehrlich
zu sein habe ich einfach seit letztem
jahr hängen gelassen
lasst uns nie vergessen worum es an
weihnachten wirklich geht etwas zu geben
zb na wer ist denn hier die kleine
umwelt sarah wär ja das ist ein bisschen
viel papier aber nur einmal in den
weihnachtstagen produziert jeder
deutsche 20 prozent mehr ab weil als
sonst verpackung kann man nicht
vermeiden geschenkpapier schon über 18
milliarden euro geben die deutschen
dieses jahr für weihnachtsgeschenke aus
wart ihr denn her internet ausgeliefert
worden von einem nachhaltigen
lieferdienste nicht das ist ein bisschen
teurer aber dafür muss man selber nicht
in die stadt fahren das sportjahr co2
ist die teure aber jedes sechste im
internet bestellte paket geht wieder
retour in deutschland übers jahr
geschätzte 280 millionen stück so
schauen wir doch mal welches geschenk
dieses jahr umgetauscht das ist für
deine frau hasst mich raten die
küchenmaschine ja aber die koch
vollautomatisch geht doch bestimmt am 27
direkt wieder zurück oder klar wie
letztes jahr
[Musik]
und staubsauger der sorgt automatisch
eine küchenmaschine echt jetzt war es
die kocht automatisch
[Musik]
weil kann man schon wieder überall
silvesterböller kaufen
jedes jahr werden in deutschland 5000
tonnen giftiger feinstaub in die luft
geblasen
mein gott herum auf ich kenne diese ich
rauche nicht ich habe kein kamel kann
man noch einmal im jahr kann man aber
besser an
ja klar 5000 tonnen das sind ungefähr 16
prozent des feinstaubs der im ganzen
jahr im deutschen straßenverkehr
entsteht
wenn papa weltweit die erde
sorry ich will euch nicht euer
weihnachtsfest verderben und gibt es
einen auch noch irgendwas zu meckern
er ist okay aber wusstet ihr eigentlich
das was co2 betrifft weil man jetzt raus
ist man auf und raus raus raus aus
meinem leben vor weihnachten werde ich
immer so emotional und da wollte ich dir
eigentlich nur noch mal da wirklich da
eigentlich nur noch mal sagen die serie
mehr auf den sarg gehst du gehst mir
auch total auf den sagen ja und wenn die
zuschauer jetzt noch auf abonnieren
drücken dann können wir uns 2020 noch
weiter offen sagt oder lasst doch
einfach einen daumen hoch oder schaut
doch einfach das nächste video von der
heute schauen weißt du eigentlich wie
viel dieses verpackte streaming in
diesem quadranten scheidt internet weißt
du eigentlich wie wir das halt dein maul
und verpestet sehr gerne kannst mich
noch mal kurz aus dem bild schubsen das
macht mir so viel spaß